nous sommes le 3 décembre bonsoir et
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 le journal et dans l'actualité
aujourd'hui non le sénat n'est pas une
chambre d'enregistrement pour son
président l'ump gérard larcher
elle doit jouer son rôle dans la vie
politique et se faire connaître des
citoyens cela passe par une présence des
élus sur le terrain rencontre tout à
l'heure avec le patron de la chambre
haute du parlement français dans sa
permanence de rambouillet au salon du
cheval la mode est au discount cette
mode lancée par une société yvelinoise
des équipements moins cher pour ouvrir
la discipline au plus grand nombre
salon du cheval jusqu'au 7 décembre et
puis retour à tout à l'heure sur ce
spectacle du cirque national de chine
c'était attrape une relecture d'alice au
pays des merveilles proposées
le temps d'un week end et pour débuter
une trentaine de jeunes yvelinois a reçu
hier son attestation de compétences
acquises il était stagiaire à l'école de
la deuxième chance de trappes ils sont
maintenant dans le monde du travail ou
en formation on les écoute alors à aider
aussi à grandir grandir pardon et aux
professionnels parce que j'avais aucune
expérience du coup avec les stages et
cetera j'ai pu me
on est un peu voilà au monde entretient
mais il réussit donc du chômage et
l'emploi ce qui est à la goutte d'or
voilà j'ai quelque chose à avoir à la
fin d'année est pour l'instant t u quoi
et c'est un parcours vraiment génial
pour moi et il ya plein de choses je
veux dire que j'ai oublié lorsque
j'étais au collège
et voilà j'ai tout à fait si tous les
maths français
moi j'étais complètement naze en un
match bah là ça va et lors de cette
soirée un partenariat a été signé entre
l'école de la deuxième chance et la cvs
qu'une entreprise spécialisée dans le
traitement de l'eau un moyen de proposer
d'autres stages professionnels au public
de l'école mais aussi d'obtenir des
fonds pour le fonctionnement à travers
la taxe d'apprentissage
c'est toujours très compliqué
financièrement on a besoin de
financements publics sont une denrée
rare et et en ce moment on est en train
de construire les budgets 2015 et c'est
une bagarre permanente ça va pas en
s'arrangeant mais par contre il ya
vraiment une volonté forte à la fois de
l'état à la fois de la région monsieur
rebsamen a eu l'occasion de répondre à
une question du gouvernement au sujet
des écoles de la deuxième chance la
semaine dernière on est en train de
s'organiser pour ça fonctionne bien mais
il ya beaucoup de villes à mettre dans
les rouages
on s'y emploie tous avec énergie c'est
plus de 10 % de notre budget donc on est
au delà de la bouffée d'air frais on est
sur une ressource nécessaire et
indispensable à l'occasion de
l'ouverture de sa nouvelle permanence à
rambouillet le président du sénat élu
sur ce secteur gérard larcher nous
reçoit pour échanger sur l'actualité
politique actualité nationale avec
l'élection de nicolas sarkozy à
l'actualité locale également avec les
prochaines élections départementales le
président ump du sénat qui revient aussi
sur le rôle qu'il entend donner à son
institution au cours des prochains mois
c'est l'entretien de cette édition du
mercredi 3 décembre
nous sommes à la permanence du président
du sénat à rambouillet bonjour gérard
larcher bonjour je suis très heureux de
vous accueillir pour cette permanence de
la rue dreyfus à rambouillet l'actualité
aujourd'hui c'est forcément l'élection à
la présidence de l'ump nicolas sarkozy
et qu'ils l'emportent avec 64 5% des
suffrages est ce que c'est un bon score
suffisant pour un président de l'ump
au-delà de ça que pensez vous des
résultats et bruno le maire et d'hervé
mariton
tout d'abord nous avons un président à
l'ump choisi clairement par un score qui
est un bon score
aujourd'hui il faut construire faut
construire une ump qui se rassemblent
qui prépare son projet et qui à la
rencontre des français leur propose une
alternative à l'échec du gouvernement
socialiste ou à l' espèce de fuite en
avant vers le populisme
nous avons une responsabilité de
formation républicaine de centre et de
droite dans lequel le gaulliste que je
suis entend jouer aux côtés du président
à la construction de ce projet avec la
sensibilité qui est la mienne on avait
parlé d'un raz-de-marée pour nicolas
sarkozy au niveau des voix s'est
visiblement pas le cas ça s'explique
aussi peut-être parler de prise de
position de nicolas sarkozy pendant la
campagne je pense au mariage pour tous
par exemple c'est à dire comment vous
positionner sur ces détails à ce sujet
moi j'ai voté contre la loi taubira je
suis même largement exprimés je ne suis
pas favorable à l'abrogation je les dis
je suis pour une réécriture
damman pour éclairer très clairement les
questions de filiation de gestation pour
autrui et notamment de procréation
médicalement assistée
voilà des sujets qui méritent la clarté
et la loi taubira n'a pas été très clair
mais pas d'abrogation parce que vous
faites la différence entre ré écriture
et l'abrogation pour nicolas sark de
grand talent n'est pas
anticonstitutionnel
mais je pense que ça n'est pas la voie
dans laquelle on doit s'engager alors
est ce que la voix du renouvellement du
mp il faut aussi engager et ça veut dire
est-ce qu'il faut changer le nom de
l'ump par exemple est-ce qu'il faut
réécrire le kart la priorité c'est de
construire un projet la projet pour la
france d'aujourd'hui
une france qui n'a plus de croissance
une france où le chômage est devenu de
bath où chaque mois on a entre 20000 et
30000 chômeurs de plus
une france qui doute une france qui est
à la traîne en europe c'est des réponses
qu'il faut apporter
et puis c'est à l'issue tout ça il
apparaît que ce vaste rassemblement doit
porter un nouveau nom pourquoi pas mais
si on commence par le non sans avoir
répondu à l'essentiel je crois qu'on
aura manqué un rendez vous et je ne
doute pas que nicolas sarkozy avec tous
le rassemblement qui va se retrouver à
l'ump n'est pas pour priorité d'abord de
construire le projet d'alternance
mesdames et messieurs les conseillers
généraux des élections va s'intéresser
plateau aux élections plus local c'est
la prochaine échéance les cantonales
inconsciemment cantonales aujourd'hui
départementale sur rambouillet il ya un
choix encore qui n'a pas été fait c'est
christine boutin la conseillère
départementale sortante vous souhaitez
qu'elle se représente ou pas d'abord à
noter que nous avons eu l'accord avec 2
quand on réservé dans les nouveaux
cantons celui montigny guyancourt et
celui de rambouillet
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines christine
boutin nous fera connaître sa décision
et votre soin quelques semaines ça lui
appartient et ça lui appartient dans un
dialogue avec les militants les citoyens
et avec le député de la circonscription
et personnellement je la rencontrerai
très bientôt
même question pour le secteur continue
de lui en cours le président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qui pourraient se présenter
face à paraîtrait logique
est ce qu'un homme politique important
du secteur donc avoir son avis prendre
en compte sa décision est quelque chose
d'essentiel et votre volonté est ce que
ce serait important qu'il soit candidat
est ce que c'est un risque qu'il soit
candidat parce qu'ils seraient face au
sortant le socialiste françois de ligne
et le même voyage c'est dans la vie
politique pur produit toujours un risque
que vous êtes candidat j'en sais quelque
chose que les rations n'y a pas autant
je pense en tous les cas que sa décision
je la partageraient le local c'est
quelque chose qui vous préoccupent vous
avez récemment discuté avec les maires
lors du congrès des maires vous avez
voulu les rassurer en leur disant qu'il
fallait faire attention
non seulement la baisse des dotations et
puis aussi à la simplification des
normes peut-être revenir sur ça
aujourd'hui c'est très compliqué pour un
élu local de mener sa commune si la
droite devait revenir aux affaires
qu'est ce que la droite changerait
depuis tous les gouvernements depuis 40
ans on a empilé des normes gouvernement
de gauche gouvernement de droite et du
centre
donc nous avons une responsabilité
partagée l'association des maires de
france a fait un calcul 400000 normes
empilés l'an dernier 2013
le conseil national d'évaluation des
normes a estimé un surcoût pour la
collectivité territoriale d'un milliard
deux cents millions
nous sommes dans une période où nous
savons que les collectivités doivent
participer à la réduction de la dépense
publique
on nous impose même brutalement 3
milliards 7 cette année
il faut impérativement aller gênés nord
les rythmes scolaires fait des nouvelles
normes imposées des décisions notamment
d'aménagement de bâtiments des normes de
sécurité certaines sont utiles d'autres
sont elles totalement indispensable si
je prends aussi l'évolution des
traitements dans la fonction publique
c'est une décision de l'état qui
s'applique aux collectivités donc
aujourd'hui les collectivités sont dans
une seringue assez pouvant table -30%
vient de dire un rapport droite et
gauche confondues au sénat de la
délégation collectivités territoriales -
30 % de capacité d'investissement ça va
avoir une conséquence dans la vie
quotidienne
d'abord dans les communes la voirie par
exemple je prends ce premier exemple
l'entretien des bâtiments
mais derrière des conséquences sur
l'emploi sur les rentrées de tva pour
l'état il faut aussi faire un calcul
le secteur du bâtiment des travaux
publics va mal tout le monde le sait et
donc pour fusionner les à
l'agglomération faire des agglomérations
plus large c'est une bonne piste
c'est ce que n'aurait pas renié ses
économies la première des pistes c'est
la clarification des compétences
la seconde des choses c'est
naturellement la mutualisation entre
communautés de communes d'agglo ou
communauté urbaine et les communes
là il faut qu'on aille plus loin et
l'amélioration des comptes de huit cent
mille habitants par alors les super
l'agglomération je suis assez réservé un
talent inné du préfet de région densité
hallyday du préfet de région
il faut qu'il s'en méfie je rappelle que
le général de gaulle avait divisé la
seine et oise pour éviter l'immensité
parce qu'il faut aussi de la proximité
aujourd'hui la commune ça reste le lieu
de la proximité et ans est en désarroi
de crise morale
vous voyez bien que seul le mr le maire
adjoint conseiller municipal à la
confiance majoritaire des élus sa mairie
de 10 avec les chiens ont parlé des
compétences ça permet de revenir tout
même sur les départements parce que
quelques compétences pour les conseils
départementaux
à partir du prochain jeu sera avait fait
un rapport d'ailleurs qui était co signé
d'un certain nombre de sénateurs dont
j'étais sous la présidence de jean
pierre raffarin avec un rapporteur
socialiste président du conseil général
de haute saône qui arrive krattinger on
avait dit le département c'est la
proximité sociale l'aide sociale à
l'enfance est ce que vous la fait
traiter dans une immense région de 11
millions d'habitants où est ce que vous
l'avez traité par une communauté de
communes de moins de vingt mille
habitants non c'est le département et la
proximité territoriale l'aménagement les
relations avec les communes c'est ça la
vision du département d'une région
stratège et notamment pour notre région
ile de france
on voit bien le rôle dans le
développement économique dans les grands
dossiers d'aménagement l'université la
recherche
vous parliez de faire le grand chelem
sur le conseil départemental dans les
yvelines l'espère il va falloir il va
falloir expliquer les compétences sirh
les électeurs pour qu'ils se mobilisent
parce que c'est un scrutin qui
mobilisent peu et là ça va évidemment
par adam et dagobert de bord et d'un
gouvernement qui n'a cessé de changer
les dates et qui je le rappelle a
présenté quatre versions différentes de
la réforme territoriale en moins de deux
ans et il faudra que le gouvernement
assume cette part d'irresponsabilité
qu'il a eu sur la réforme territoriale
ce sera à nous à l'issue du débat du
sénat de dire quel département nous
voulons une dernière question vous êtes
président du sénat vous souhaitez un
bicamérisme très vivant vous souhaitez
aller à la rencontre des électeurs leur
expliquer ce que fait le sénat
concrètement ça va se traduire comme en
permanence y en a le cdh a hors les murs
des sénateurs qui rend compte est
citoyen qui rencontre la vie économique
la vie sociale du pays ceddat qui
examine complètement les projets de loi
de finances qui les amendes un sénat qui
examine l'ensemble des textes qui les
rejette pas a priori et et moi même
dans la permanence ici à rambouillet au
7 de la rue dreyfus ou 7 bis je veux
être à la rencontre des citoyens la
rencontre décès du parent ce que je
n'oublie pas que ma légitimité
elle est en yvelines c'est là où j'ai
reçu mandat au suffrage universel
indirect des élus municipaux des élus
départementaux et régionaux
mais les élus municipaux et les élus des
citoyens et ils forment 96% de mon corps
électoral doit les rencontrer je dois
aller voir
voilà pourquoi je me rends dans les
communes et je vais me rendre dans
toutes les communes voilà pourquoi aussi
je souhaite que les citoyens n'hésitent
pas à venir rencontrer leurs sénateurs
et leur sénateur des yvelines
tant qu'à faire le président tenait à
ses liens à l'archet doux au travers de
la présence de bénévoles mais aussi
d'une collaboratrice parlementaire
professionnels la possibilité de se
rencontrer et moi même d'être présent
pour recevoir en rendez vous aussi bien
les élus quel citoyen laquelle les
journalistes comme aujourd'hui merci
madame gérard la merci d'être venus la
suite de ce journal est toujours en
politique pierre bédier président ump du
conseil général des yvelines vient
d'apporter son soutien au principe du
pass navigo valérie pécresse la chef de
file de l'opposition régionale
responsable local de l'ump s'est montré
très critique envers un tarif unique une
mesure portée par le socialiste jean
paul huchon les écologistes rappelons
avec la carte mensuelle à tarif unique
donc pourrait rentrer en vigueur en
septembre 2015 pour un montant de 70
euros en attendant elle les tarifs des
transports en commun en ile de france
devraient augmenter en janvier de près
de 3% en moyenne hausse de la tva crise
économique l'équitation est elle
épargnée par la crise au salon du cheval
à villepinte certaines entreprises se
démarque et se met est à vendre des
équipements équestres à prix cassés à
violaines 13 et le diwan se sont rendus
elles se sont arrêtées sur les stands de
deux de ses entreprises basée dans les
yvelines
reportage c'est la deuxième fois que
véronique délocalisent de ses produits
sur le salon du cheval à villepinte
dans sa boutique basée à houdan dans les
yvelines elle propose des équipements
pour chevaux et cavaliers
sa particularité vendre des produits
haut de gamme mais à des prix cassés et
accessible à tous car le monde de
l'équitation n'est pas épargné par la
crise ça va encore plus les tout chez
eux
pourquoi parce que parce que le
gouvernement a changé la tva et à fait d
augmentation colossale sur sur le prix
des pensions et donc forcément le
cavalier va d'abord mettre tous dans son
fall et gardera les miettes pour lui
véronique a ouvert sa boutique il y a un
an en pleine période de crise pour voir
si elle est bien positionnée par rapport
aux autres marques et toucher une
clientèle pas seulement régional mais
aussi national
le salon du cheval est l'endroit idéal
l'investissement est lourd 11000 euros
pour un stand de 40 mètres carrés durant
les neuf jours de l'événement à voir les
clients qui s'arrêtent son concept
d'équitation discount attire dans un
univers de passionnés et non de business
c'est plutôt nouveau mais comment vendre
des produits équestre à prix cassés sa
société est récente c'est trésorerie est
encore insuffisant pour acheter des
volumes importants aux fournisseurs
alors il faut trouver d'autres solutions
je vais plutôt travailler avec une
marque l'a travaillé suffisamment bien
pour qu'il me donne une marge arrière et
cette marge arrière je l'offre à mes
clients pour que le produit reste
accessible à quelques mètres de là une
autre entreprise chinoise a fait le
déplacement
ici même concept tout type d'équipement
et aux meilleurs prix possibles dans
cette série basée au mesnil-le-roi
depuis 16 ans le gérant a vu évoluer les
achats des consommateurs moins
d'accessoires mode acheter mais plus
d'accessoires technique il ya quelques
années il ya 4 5 ans on était plus sur
les produits futile aujourd'hui les gens
se recentre sur les produits utiles et
de bonne qualité
bon prix une consommation différente qui
l'a amené il ya trois ans environ à
revoir ses méthodes de vente
on a concentré nos achats sur moine
marque mais plus avec des volumes plus
importants de manière justement à
pouvoir proposer ces prix plus
intéressants
voilà tout à fait le salon du cheval se
tient jusqu'à dimanche au parc des
expositions de villepinte sport les
mondiaux de cyclisme se dérouleront du
18 au 22 février au vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
championnats du monde sur piste pour
lesquels la billetterie est d'ores et
déjà ouvertes et pour les saint
quentinois des remises le pack famille
un jour et par exemple à 73 euros au
lieu de 81 ans la france avait elle déjà
organiser cet événement en 98 et en 2006
mais à bordeaux
la fédération française de cyclisme qui
parle de reconnaissance après les
efforts réalisés pour ériger ce
vélodrome ce site
toujours en cyclisme le 8 mars va
s'élancer la 73e édition du paris-nice
c'est la sixième fois que cette
compétition débutera dans les yvelines
prologue à maurepas et première étape à
saint rémy les chevreuse anthony h entre
paris nice et les yvelines
l'histoire d'amour ne s'arrête plus les
8 9 mars prochain la course au soleil
s'élancera pour la sixième fois du
département la vache heureuse c'est
indissociable de la mémoire et la
légende de jacques anquetil les grandes
années les grands prix les nations n'ont
que du grand prix des nations dans les
années 50 jusqu'aux championnats du
monde sur piste en février prochain et à
paris nice l'année prochaine comme ces
cinq dernières années et comme encore au
moins deux autres deux ou trois années
ça veut bien dire quelque chose il ya
surtout dans les yvelines ce lien
évident réel concret entre la pratique
de la bicyclette au quotidien et le
cyclisme des champions avec l'ouverture
du vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et ses 70
mille hectares de forêt le département
des yvelines est désormais une terre
propice à toutes les pratiques du vélo
et a eu un peu plus d'édition en dehors
des gis linke dans les yvelines
mais c'est vrai que ces six dernières
éditions ont vu s'associer un
département qui est un département
précise
puisque à la fois de cyclotourisme
mais aussi de cyclisme de compétition
avec maintenant le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
contrairement à 2014 un prologue de 6 km
700 lancera la course à travers la ville
de maurepas des coureurs devraient
partir du parc du bout des clos en
passant par la rue de la tour pour
terminer du côté du boulevard michel
miserait c'est une fierté
je pense que je ne pouvais pas espérer
mieux en tout cas en début de mandat
d'accueillir cette 13e édition du
paris-nice ce prologue
parce que voilà ça va démarrer le
dimanche au 8 mars
pour ce qui concerne la course mais pour
ce qui concerne l'animation dans la
ville ça commençait déjà dès le samedi
donc on va en profiter vraiment pour en
faire rayonner la ville de maurepas au
lendemain du prologue la première étape
partira de saint rémy les chevreuse pour
une destination encore inconnue mais le
peloton devrait se diriger vers le loir
et cher pour le reste du tracé
il faudra attendre le 3 février et la
présentation officielle de cette 73e
édition sport toujours dernier round de
répétition ce moment pour ahmed el
moussaoui il va tenter dans quelques
jours de décrocher la ceinture
européenne des poids welters l'occasion
pour ce représentant de la verrière de
montrer qu'il a franchi un nouveau
palier dans sa carrière pour devenir
l'un des tous meilleurs de sa catégorie
c ie transpire l'ambition et la rage de
vaincre
un an après son titre de champion de
france ahmed el moussaoui s'attaque à la
ceinture de l'union européenne des
welters en l'espace de douze mois le
prince de la boxe française énormément
mûri et s'est professionnalisé suivi par
un ostéopathe et un diététicien le
vernis roy s'est entouré d'un
préparateur physique jean baptiste
combourg dos pour ne plus penser qu'à la
boxe
j'essaie de me tall chances de mon côté
un cap encore à franchir non je suis
classé jeu classé 9e européen je pense
que après ce combat là pour moi je
actuellement je fais partie des
meilleurs européens
après maintenant voilà ça moi de prouver
que je le suis vraiment pour le ring il
a également changé d'entraîneur le
chapitre américain est refermé c'est
désormais youssef ben ari qui s'occupe
de lui entre les cordes avec lui ahmed
el moussaoui travail plus l'aspect
tactique d'un combat mon ancien
entraîneur aux etats-unis c'était plus
du long et ses plus de résistance par
contre là c'est plus court on va dire
1h30 2h vraiment mais super intensifs et
les entraînements sont beaucoup plus
variés et je sens la progression du feu
tel un scientifique youssef barritt
décrypte le moindre des mouvements de
son boxeur l'objectif excellé dans la
simplicité pour s'éviter toute mauvaise
surprise le jour du combat
c'est un boxeur l'on chérit grand pour
sa catégorie donc avec une grande
amplitude de bras c'est quelqu'un de
mobiles de combatif de rapide mais qui
prend trop de risques
voilà alors c'est bien pour le public
c'est bien pour ses fans et c'est moins
bien pour la suite de sa carrière
il faut le préserver ses qualités un
petit peu de combattants va le
desservent un petit peu de ce jour là à
l'entraînement son partenaire n'est
autre que le challenger pour la ceinture
européenne des super welters
karim est rouge et au bout de quelques
reprises ahmed enlève son casque de
protection comme pour ressentir un peu
plus l'intensité du combat que pourrait
lui réserver son adversaire car il lui
faudra faire face au champion d'espagne
aitor nieto un boxeur longiligne de 30
ans au même profil physique que le
français 6 avec seulement une défaite en
22 combats le verrier roi part favori il
devra confirmer les espoirs placés en
lui depuis son titre national
réponse le 6 décembre prochain et pour
terminer ce journal retour à présent sur
le spectacle proposé par le cirque
national de chine le week-end dernier à
trappes les acrobates ont proposé une
relecture et d'alice au pays des
merveilles
l'oeuvre de lewis carroll à son
cinquante deux ans aujourd'hui mais pas
une ride mélanie poker william l
j'ai un lapin blanc en retard comme un
air de déjà vu
alice au pays des merveilles le compte
est bien connu mais ces personnages-là
son moderne ancré dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui et chinois étant pauvre
dans la chine d'aujourd'hui
lewis carroll est encore plus fou à son
époque c'était plus sage crâne
c'est un personnage très mystérieux même
si les replacer dans la chine
d'aujourd'hui il reste avec tout son
mystère sur notre roman britannique
artistes chinois et créateurs français
un melting-pot où les traditions des uns
et des autres se mélangent
bourgeois toussaint y tient on a
progressé sur le plan du jeu d'acteur
car avant on chine n'était pas très
développée il suffisait de sourire et
c'est tout avec le metteur en scène
français on a appris est-ce que ça
vienne de l'intérieur va montrer les
émotions même dans la musique qu'il y a
des instruments chinois c'est important
de montrer notre culture
tous les arts du cirque sont chinois
une folie poétique interprété par 25
artistes acrobates magiciens
contorsionniste ils ont entre 15 et 30
ans ils viennent de l'académie de
tianjin au sud de pékin
après plus d'une heure et demie et 18
tableaux les spectateurs ne s'y sont pas
trompés j'ai beaucoup admiré les
artistes c'est un travail considérable
et c'est magique des meilleurs cercles
que j'ai pouvoir donc c'est vrai à une
réinterprétation moderne du conte de
lewis carroll qui est à la fois très
moderne très asiatique et
très fraîche ou le public trappistes est
tombé sous le charme
alice elle est déjà reparti dans
quelques instants sur téléphiles
kiosques de l'hebdomadaire de la culture
à demain jeudi dès 18 heures pour une
édition du journal très largement
consacrée au téléthon d'ici là bonne
soirée